logo bro okay what's up everyone my name
is hey I'm floor gang if your ceiling
gang cringe
today we're watching another you blade
that's right I like fun
these are fun this one is a very special
title it's six non-virgins versus one
secret version
did you know statistically half of
everyone is very secretly virgin and I'm
not verging so that means episode this
is the show odd man out where your
judgments are thrown out the window
out the window which is what you will
you will be thrown out the window if you
have pretty non premarital sex I'm
really good at delivering jokes out the
window not on my watch we want to gift
more crewnecks that we're gonna give it
to the most insightful comments yeah
that the most insightful comments I've
never seen anyone bully so hard as the
Jubilee comments they are completely no
they don't
you're the only one and I can't already
not wait what they gonna say about this
guy Harris Harris
I need my peepee big strong calm cool
yeah why I'm in my pee pee Pikachu
because it will shock you yeah is it I
get it we all named our pee pee at one
point in my life but not when you're old
okay that's unforgivable this guy's to
me he's the virgin right now brought
together seven non-virgins
alright I'll just be blind this episode
it's fine I don't is a virgin I am NOT a
virgin I am NOT I am NOT a virgin
goddamnit everytime when I watch these I
cuz I think I'm good at gauging people
every time when they do that I'm not I'm
like I should be able to pick you up but
I can't it's too hard a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives he or she wins the
entire prize but if you win that means
you're virgin so do you really win
somebody to think about I say we just
start asking questions and everyone
answers that's a pretty good strategy I
like that that's that point out there
shop god I think that's why the Cubs are
so savage because it's so easy to just
sit here and we're like that's the
dumbest [ __ ] I've ever heard
no what we really should do is we don't
we should all just have sex right here
because that means everyone won't be a
virgin and we all win the money easy
come on oh you're not a virgin prove it
huh have sex right now you could try
that oh you're not a virgin that's not
vegan
sorry too many tangents fine Nishal was
Sean he seemed too confident too
talkative let's go around the circle
figure it out yeah everyone that's a
virgin cannot be confident whatsoever
they have to walk constantly in shame
what do you call yours Harris Harris age
[Laughter]
really all right he's still diverting to
me on MySpace what myspace on myspace I
put my peepee in your peepee you know I
actually got married on in in video
games when I was 12 so yeah it's
whatever
I hope [ __ ] it was it was an it an
online RPG I don't remember their name
but it was kind of a big deal okay
her name was Demon Slayer 64 we don't
tell might see about that okay she
doesn't have to know I feel like
everyone wanted to control the situation
we weren't getting anywhere when was the
last time you guys
two days ago three days yeah are they
gonna eliminate anyone based on this
yeah yeah who's that oh my god they're
all going what would you vote her out
this is so confusing
I mean I don't know what they've said
they clearly cut the footage man that is
very key item no I trusted you
I was shocked or Emily I don't think at
first glance wait hello hello they
eliminated that girl before this guy or
the frickin guy with the pony t-shirt a
rainbow pony that dabs okay all right
you played the game the way you want to
play a shot or Emily I don't think at
first glance I look like a virgin no
that guy does that guy just how much
money do they win by the way great so
when you lost your virginity
okay so nuts then how to go down High
School both virgins didn't know what the
hell we were doing it was the first
letter of her first exact correct J
bloom at 21 would that mean that makes
no sense
all right I was late bloomer - I
wouldn't pull some 21 she was my
coworker so kind of scandalous what
about you
her name was harmony and how'd you guys
meet my space my space you next there
was harmony we met on myspace where were
widely in love harmony you next sounds
almost as realist Demon Slayer 64 in me
but okay I was 14 it will last about two
minutes
so it sounds like a great exchange how
was your first experience two minutes I
mean it's probably accurate loss to a
girl named Stacy Stacy and in back of my
Volvo I was okay with late bloomer I was
believe I was in college and how did you
lose it like where was it that in my
apartment
slash dorm that wasn't I lived question
why does he answer like a question right
I believe was my it was my apartment
very suspicious and this is already a
big red flag how many people have you
slept with oh gosh under 10 under a
thousand believe her maybe maybe a
couple thousand or something I don't
know see this hickey a guy here yeah
that's whatever I had sex last night
I'm 25 25 old med I had a thousand girls
harmony harmony one harmony to harmony
three it was great hickeys were cool
when you were you were a teenager you're
25 dude
Jesus Christ you get a hickey when
you're not a teenager he punched right
away thrown out the window right away
because he was playing the game so hard
I was like hey she suck with her lip she
did come to win to the point of giving
himself a fake hickey
relationship few months I don't know I
don't know anything I just like figured
that maybe get rid of the guy with the
pony t-shirt I mean yeah to be fair
TV I also I don't think it is that him
because it's never the obvious one in
these I've learned that much at least if
it's obvious we have to yeah it's also
fair I can see though I'm kind of
flattered I didn't want to be too
defensive no I'm not I'm not a virgin
just because I'm kind of like it's okay
if you are
what oh absolutely unless you're married
of course you guys have had sex like an
obstacle course on my college campus
like one of those rope course things an
obstacle course how does that happen I
feel like I have too many points to make
in this video it's just so weird what
everyone says obstacle course
hey girls see that obstacles you see
that obstacle course over there I bet we
could slam it out in the obstacle course
how does that happen
guess if we don't have anywhere else
let's hit the obstacle course
she's definitely saying and I actually
don't think he is as well but I would
still vote him out just for the shirt
you should try the obstacle course yeah
Jonathan is a hive mentality you just
want to be safe and do whatever it takes
yeah see
[Music]
damn everyone I had a different shirt I
was told that this shirt worked fine I
feel like that may have contributed also
maybe don't judge people by the shirts
that they choose to bro you had another
shirt and you wore that one wait
Jubilees said it was fine to wear it too
really
hey I have this house a shirt that says
I'm a virgin on it is that is that
cooler I got another one I could change
it no that's fine
keep that shirt that's fine if it isn't
Jonathan
boy oh boy will I have learned a lesson
today about not judging people by their
shirt they wear whatsoever most favorite
aspect of sex what you guys like the
most about sex I liked it that's my
favorite part
I'm not a virgin by the way my favorite
part of sex is day that's my that's my
favorite part because I have sex I
totally had sex my favorite part is that
[Music]
that's what I know that's just my
preference definitely not a virgin I
suspect the flower boy and how long have
you been with your wavering six months
how long were you singing before that oh
I had another boyfriend from the movie
theater but we broke up those new
boyfriend and then I had a one-night
stand
that was three okay I mean that's
actually believable statistically if we
eliminated her we'd make more money
type time at that what what what he did
say so he just confirmed that he doesn't
think it's her but he wants to eliminate
her to make more
this guy is either the best actor and a
virgin or he's just a douche bag I can't
wait to read the comments goddammit I
there it is
statistically if we limited her we'd win
more money didn't find the virgin but
the douche is very I mean he's not wrong
why I heard though that's so mean
yeah you had sex the least amount of
time you gotta go yeah you don't know
come on I rather be in a relationship
than just have sex with anyone just
bullying now oh wow she took her toe she
did the whole arm thing like you you
like you like look at that I notice
issue oh good for you but you're going
cuz she was the most introverted does he
know what the point you're supposed to
find the March ahead god I hope he
doesn't lean still there good luck yeah
it's their discontent in the group I
think it's one of the black out
understand they always pick the ones
that you don't think it is she like you
said three in the last two weeks but so
I went to Palm Springs two weeks ago and
then two days ago I had sex with someone
so I did team we just kind of like
looked at each other we're just like
okay we kind of knew that we were safe I
think he could potentially still be the
more all right to ask questions were you
religious to before you had sex yeah
so if I called your mom right now and I
was like he's had sex a few times she
probably already thinks I do I mean I've
never told her do that no one in their
right mind would do that
yeah back of the Volvo what color was a
Volvo by the way it was gold gold damn
alright as far as the Volvo did you have
like padding in there or was it just
like what was the but was the body part
that hurt most after you finished my
vote is on fire flower guy in the guy's
house that were out and his parents were
gone usually 30 to 70 18 yeah yep
the MAV seems off every damn no she said
70 so she had a new guy that means
statistically she had a new guy every 20
days since 14th
I'm not shaming but that's a lot a into
now that's up there I don't think it's
anything like that but she could be
coming in here trying to be like I'm the
coolest she's saying a big number she's
young therefore I believe it because if
she was coming in here as a mole she
really know the guy that comes the
person that came in to say think they're
the coolest is definitely this guy I'm
all she I think she's safe and that
global story about your knees that that
makes sense I'm a sex symbol okay well
he's good needed to like sway one of
them so I was thinking like Trevor was
the mole okay we'll just go with a
manual for now but he wasn't budging I
don't think he has a beard with like a
tattoo he didn't throw me in the fire
it's kind of like you know what you're
cool you know throw me and me and
Emanuel started kind of indirectly
teaming up to like telepathically if you
think so do you think no other point of
the game at this point or have they just
forgotten it seems like they're just
trying to bully each other they throw
out the girl because she was the most
introverted and then they team up
because they didn't throw it they don't
like a tactic game of not being the
virgin
he bought the Hickey was a point like a
bottle cap you just put on his neck
bottle cap how does that work oh that's
really everybody's you know it's not
hard to recreate that I thought it was
real but I thought it was a little
scripted I know it's not you yeah those
numbers did they work they work do I got
a hickey did it work
can't see all right who's going out no
matter what it would have been - V - it
was obvious that Sean and Jolie we're
gonna vote Trevor off and then try and
get me off yeah I think the mole is
probably out but I want money so here we
go oh my god boy I'm so glad he didn't
once I'm so happy
people don't expect me to be a virgin
and unless asked I don't say anything I
get it it's the game survival of the
fittest so I I understand yeah the game
that no one played properly associate
self-proclaimed sex symbol no you are
you're the socio bad
you really never know so I'm still a
virgin because I'm waiting for marriage
all right fair enough
sex is a covenant between me God and my
future wife all right well well playing
well that promise to myself and my
family and to God that I would wait
until marriage knowing as he was at
least it was that was a good episode I
enjoy that now let's read all the
comments that is what kind of bully him
imagine being 25 thinking it's cool to
flex hickeys yeah pretty much
Sean looks like that's not a version of
someone that you want to be damn they
really kicked Emily out just because she
was the most wholesome it I felt kind of
good that she got voted out when she
started saying something about hi mind
mentally I really felt disgusted with
her what I'm just happy Sean or Julie
did say Jonathan and a manual yeah I
wished it don't stay longer on that was
funny
honestly it would have been like Sean
has to be a virgin because who would
want to sleep with him bro
why is everyone treating virgin like
insult bura oh yes she did say that
don't judge a book by its cover
also Julie in the back of my mind I was
judging of laughs they look oh god she's
18 and already had 30 to 70 partners
Burt okay alright alright time to end
there pursue there I hope you guys
enjoyed if you did smash like actually
you don't even have to smash it you can
just give it a little tap that's all you
gotta do subscribe upload videos every
single day and I see gamers tomorrow
floor gang out
[Music]
of the pp to crush the rest and get a
pee
Jennifer grumpy sleepy bear reach the
photo found on Shannon sponsee Edgar
Maya Tuskegee sword bill three questions
boiling what your colleague singing fix
the lid some across the world but then
from dusk till dawn and I borrow your
power cord my ball is down and you know
terrace-flat
I gotta commit birch Colbert comma Molly
Claudia Rudy roll the King clinching for
Istanbul is falling falling what you're
calling pinging pixel ease
stronger than me how many pictures she
you have from breath down to crunch of
pollen this is my son as you noticed
that love will soon be gosh Louie push
you are see Ted nicer up do rock cement
for the Sally
[Applause]
picture lips
the craters game of all time download it
now before to it this song is a
commercial I'm spoiling spoiling what
you call a king in I'm spoil he's
falling spoiling weren't you calling
singing boys boys bowling ball
Big Sur legs
[Music]